Ngày ngày 15 tháng 6, cô đổi đầu quân sự giữa Israen và Irran bước sẵn ngày trở chính.
Giáo tránh tiếp tục giả tăng với tưởng độ ngay một cao.
Giảy đã vuy nhân giảm sử lượng thế lượng nhằm và Israen sau với những ngày đầu xung đột.
Một quan trước tóc cao Irran tình bố,
thế Irran hiện đã chuyển sẵn trên lược tấn công tập trung và trở lượng sử dụng có lã thế lợi hiện đại.
Có độ chính giá cao, thay vì phòng hàng loại như trước.
Vì này, bác bỏ tín đồ nhân giang có thế lượng của Irran sắp cả.
Đông thời khẳng định gá lỗi thế lượng của Irran vẫn có cả năng xuân thùng.
Hẹt thống phòng công tiết tiền của Israen phọc thập chi lạ của Mỹ.
Giảy sạch cũng ngày 25 tháng 6,
lượng phòng về Israen i đã em chình khai 5 mili tâm tích tập kích sau và lãnh thổ Irran.
Một tiêu trình lạc có sự hạnh nhân Israhan cũng bốn bệ phòng tiêu hạnh phẩm.
Israhan, tuyến bố tiêu diện nhiều chi vý có cao của lượng về bình kích mạng huy giảo Irran,
iro, có say trong đó có 2 tri huy thuộc lực lượng quốc.
Fiat Irran sân nhận cơ sở hạnh nhân vi hư hải nhưng chưa sân nhận thường bằng của các tri huy.
Irran đã trả lại bằng đưa tấn công tiêu lượng đạn đạo lần thứ mười tắm,
trong chiến dịch trả đủ ở lời hữa đích thử ba.
Một tiêu lạc các cơ sở chiến lượng tại miệng bác và miệng Trung Israen trong đó có cả sân bay của tế Vèn Buryon gần trò biết.
Hình ảnh trên mạng sơ hội gí nhận các phụ nổ lượng nhưng chưa Israen chưa sân nhận thử hải.
Về ngoài rau trong chuyến công dù thổ như kì ngoài trường Irran à bác róc chi trên bố,
nước này sẽ không đàn phản với Mỹ, Nếu Israen tiếp tục vĩ trị khai nọc thủ định.
Tuy nhiên, tây hi ra and vẫn định ngọt cả nắng lối thoại hạn nhân vở nhỏ bán nước trò ôi e ba,
gồm anh pháp và đức.